[Music]
plants are the foundation for all life
understanding plant diversity is
critical to our continued survival
[Music]
the goal of the world flora online is to
accumulate in one place on a website a
description and illustrations of every
known plant species
[Music]
we are about five years into the process
we are accumulating new specimens we're
digitizing them and all of that
information feeds in ultimately to the
world floor online
the main way that our specimens come to
us is that they are collected in the
field
when they're here they are mounted onto
stiff paper
the information about the plant is
transcribed onto a little label that
goes along with the specimen
[Music]
a good mounter can do about 50 specimens
per day
[Music]
once the specimens are mounted we
photograph them
then that information goes online pretty
much immediately
[Music]
the project began in 2010 and it is
meant to be completed by 2020.
[Music]
we've photographed
about 2.6 million of our specimens
worldwide it must be on the order of 10
or 15 million
plants are endlessly fascinating and we
have to know what they are and how they
differ from one another in order to
understand what kind of measures need to
be taken to protect them
[Music]
this sculpture garden located in japan
was primarily unknown to the world until
2016 when a photographer stumbled upon
it
[Music]
there are around 800 sculptures in this
park depicting a mix of buddhist deities
and what are believed to be replicas of
real people
all were commissioned by a wealthy
japanese man named mutsuo furukawa
he is said to have paid 6 billion yen
around 60 million us dollars to create
this collection in 1989.
there is a large statue of furukawa
which stands overlooking the park
people depicted are said to be his
friends and family but it is unclear if
they had any knowledge of their stony
replicas
they stand near a japanese village the
name of which translates to the village
where you can meet buddha's statues
although these lifelike statues stare
with blank expressions visitors say
there is an unsettling feeling to this
place and a concern that at night these
effigies aren't so still
there's a world-renowned topiary garden
in the tiny town of bishopville south
carolina and that garden was created by
this man
a man named pearl
[Music]
i'm prairie frye
and this is my garden
pearl started the garden in 1981 with
the goal of winning yard of the month
from the local garden club i went to a
neighborhood to buy a house and the
reason they didn't want to sell me a
house they said
i wouldn't keep her behind there was a
stereotype at the time that
african-americans didn't keep up their
yards
so i figured
one year out of the month and the person
that made that statement could
understand you can't judge people by one
person
once i got yelled at my people couldn't
believe it
pearl now has over 300 plants
most of which were throwaways that came
from the recycling bin at a local
nursery i don't water i don't spray i
don't feel like i use no chemicals it's
all natural it's all pretty well done
organically
some of my tallest plants that was
recycled is around 30 feet
[Music]
so many people drove by pearl's house to
see his garden that he opened it up to
the public
i would say about 10 000 people visiting
my garden every year what else do you
want to look at
people come from all over the world to
see it
i had people from australia
japan korea
i wanted to share it because
so many people came out and wanted to
see it
he very seldom see something
got out so simple and make an impact
that this god has made
the garden is about love
and the last thing you see before you
leave my garden
in love peace and good
[Music]
a trophy belladonna will kill you
detura will put you to sleep forever
akon item will kill you
laurel will
produce cyanide and kill you
every plant here in the poison garden is
poisonous and has the ability to kill
you
[Music]
my name's trevor jones and i'm the head
gardener of anik garden this plant is
giant hogweed it will get up to around
about eight foot high it's phototoxic so
will burn your skin and give you
blisters for up to seven years
this garden is set in the wall garden of
the old castle in northumberland uk
we'd have around about 95 plants and
we're adding to the collection all the
time
this plant is akinatum or monkshood
wonderful blue flowers but the whole of
the plant is poisonous the berries
crushed up and fed you will kill you the
leaves themselves will kill you also as
will the root and the stem we have to
obviously maintain the garden so we have
to tend the plants and when we do that
we have to be very careful of the way we
operate so we have to cover some of our
skin when we deal with particularly
dangerous plants
this plant is laurel it produces cyanide
and we all know what that'll do to you
so it's the brainchild of the duchess
dutchess of northumberland so rather
than having a herb garden she decided to
create more interest and have a poison
garden they're very very common plants
in fact a lot of them are what we call
cottage garden plants and they're grown
in many people's gardens but people
don't know how harmful they actually are
this is a tropo belladonna four berries
are enough to kill a child
people are intrigued by poisonous plants
and often very worried when they come
out because many of them will be growing
these plants at home
they don't realise the powerful impact
plants can have on us as humans
is it something that you find
fascinating definitely why
it's a good way to get rid of your life
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
located in a waterfront park known as
gardens by the bay is super tree grove
this mechanical forest is a utopia for
nature in a very urban location
[Music]
super tree grove was commissioned by the
singapore government
with the intention of raising the
quality of life for its residents
by enhancing greenery and flora in the
city
this man-made mechanical forest consists
of 18 super trees
[Applause]
the trees range between 80 to 160 feet
high
and are connected by a walkway which
allows visitors to cross between them
and view the city from the treetops
with their thick trunks and network of
thin neuron-like branches
each tree acts as a vertical garden
[Music]
over 160 000 varieties of orchids ferns
and other climbing plants have been
planted in the trees the trees also
generate solar power 11 of the trees are
fitted with solar photovoltaic systems
that convert sunlight into energy this
provides lighting that allows the trees
to come alive at night making this an
all-day
all-season
horticultural heaven
[Music]
rising out of the tuscan hills are some
colorful and unusual figures
inspired by tarot cards
[Music]
the tarot park is located in tuscany a
few hours outside of rome
the park took 20 years to complete and
includes 22 figures from the tarot deck
there's a sphinx that leads to a golden
skeleton riding a blue horse over a
green sea
this represents death
the hanged man can be found inside one
of the sparkling grottos suspended from
the ceiling
and one of the most bizarre figures is
the oracle which is a hollow-eyed figure
surrounded and covered by snakes
the eccentric artist who created this
garden was nikki de saint-foal
in the early 1950s mickey was committed
to an asylum and believes it was art
that eventually healed her
she wanted to create a place that would
have the same healing effect on those
who visited
the park opened in 1998 just four years
before nikki's death
in her own words she dreamt of building
a garden that would be a dialogue
between sculpture and nature
a place to dream in
[Music]
you